To learn Muslim advocacy for Palestinian
rights and the refutations against the
arguments of the Zionist movement, I
will be teaching a 10-week course at the
Quran Institute for online and on-site
students on Palestine advocacy. The
10-week course will consist of 30 hours
of lesson time and an almost equal
amount of tutorial time that will go
in-depth into the history of Palestine,
its peoples throughout history, the
Zionist movement, arguments and
justifications they use, the plight of
the Palestinians as a result of Zionism
both in history and today, and
understanding the solutions for the
occupation of Palestine.
For all those who want to seriously
challenge what is going on in Palestine
and make our campaign to bring
international pressure to bear upon
Israel as would happen to South Africa,
we need to equip ourselves with powerful
knowledge about the history of Palestine
and know how to counter Zionist
arguments indisputably. So, join me on
the 10-week course and raise the bar on
Muslim advocacy for justice and the
rights of oppressed brothers and sisters
in Palestine. Register at
thequran.institute/palestine.
Um Israel is just another case study in
the
crimes of nationalism in that it is a
nation-state exclusively for one racial
group. Doesn't mean that it excludes
other racial groups, but the
nation-state only represents one
particular group, which is usually
facilitated by a a hopeful majority of
that particular group. So, now now to go
back to the founders of Zionism as you
mentioned um them.
Um Theodor Herzl basically
didn't really give much regard to the
natives of Palestine. Didn't give much
regard to how they're going What about
their aspirations? Uh what about their
representation in government? What about
government for them? So, first yes, he
tried to ask the Ottoman Caliph uh if he
could if he could sell it if they could
sell the land to the Zionists, and of
course he said no.
Uh but nationalism doesn't just say oh
well okay then fair dues, we'll accept
that. No, nationalism says we need to
try all the strategies because the ends
justifies
um the
the means if it is necessary for the
national interest. If it is necessary
for the national interest. And so, they
looked to other avenues and Britain was
a a very willing avenue, especially the
money and the support and it was also
advantageous for Britain at the time. Uh
Balfour gave an introduction to a book
on the history of Zionism, so he was
certainly a a solid supporter of um
Zionism. If you think that um
that the colonies in South Africa or the
colonies of the the pilgrims of the the
Puritan pilgrims in Pennsylvania
uh were were colonies were were settler
colonies, uh these were established
mainly at the resources of private
individuals, of course with the
permission of the various governments uh
or the Dutch uh East the Dutch East
India Company,
um which were private corporations
establishing these colonies. And we have
no problem calling them settler
colonies, but suddenly we have a problem
uh with calling the Zionist project,
which was established with um
international banking institutions,
organizations that were called coloniz-
colonization organizations, with no
regard to the natives. Uh why should
that be different? And I'm going to
quote you something and and then I'll
let you kind of um come back very
briefly. Uh so, he said uh the idea of
colonization of Palestine is, moreover,
connected with the remarkable colonizing
impetus which has taken hold of the
entire modern world. And judged by
outward characteristics are the European
migrations to foreign lands, their
colonization and development. So, very
different So, very different from the
this feature of Jewish aspirations. So,
is this very different from the the
feature of Jewish aspirations? He's
saying, he has a question mark there.
Exuberant energy finds no appropriate
outlet in Europe and so seek it far away
where it may be usefully employed for
the furthering of civilization in the
midst of backward countries and nations.
Fruitful Jewish energy, which is being
kept under in the diaspora, will be
gathered and transplanted to Palestine
that it may prove true to itself and to
the whole of civilization.
Um so, they describe themselves as
settler colonists. They used the the the
the terminology and they even compared
their aspirations to the European
colonization project. They said, "Are we
so different to them?" as a positive
thing cuz because everyone was doing at
the time. They said, "Why don't we get a
piece of THE ACTION? WHY CAN'T WE DO
exactly the same thing?" So, that would
be my main rebuttal to it to it. And as
I said, uh settler colonialism being
where a group of people who they they
carry their sovereignty with them and
they basically take over the sovereignty
of a land which might have other people,
which can involve and most likely
usually does involve the transplantation
or the exiting um of those people. And
to kind of finish up, I'll also mention
Theodor Herzl wrote in his diary on the
12th of June, 1895,
he said regarding lands, said, "When we
occupy the lands in Palestine, we shall
bring forth
immediate benefits to the state that
that receives us.
We must expropriate gently the private
property on the estates assigned to us.
We shall try to spirit the penniless
population across the border by
procuring employment for it in transit
countries while denying it any
employment in our country."
Okay, so
um he basically said that even though he
didn't talk about forced expulsion, but
he talked about a type of expropriation
of the property in the lands of the
people within the lands which are
appropriate which are given to them by
whichever power of course, and the
spiriting away, so putting the penniless
population which which already exist
there,
uh finding ways to get them to other
places, move them other places,
which he hoped by the carrot, you know,
not by the stick, but by the carrot,
which is try to get employment for them
in um other countries. And this was also
uh replicated by uh this this sentiment
was also mentioned by uh many of the
earliest the the late Zionist founders
who talked about um
finding employment for uh landless Arabs
which were being created due to the
Zionist colonization and denying them
employment back in Palestine. So, they
couldn't they couldn't find any
employment back in Palestine and only
available employment would be outside of
Palestine and then they can leave
Palestine. So, that would be uh that
point. So, basically, it's settler
colon- colonialism. Transfer of the
population, although at the at the
beginning it was only envisioned by the
carrot, not by the stick. Uh they they
compared themselves to other colonial
colonial projects, um many settler
colonial projects which we would always
call we would have no problem calling
settler colonialism uh like the Puritans
in Pennsylvania setting up their colony
under British char- charter. They didn't
use any soldiers from the crown to do
so. Uh the Dutch East India Company in
South Africa, they didn't use state
soldiers to do so to take over
colonialism land.
It was a private venture by themselves,
but they had permission from their their
government. Um how is Zionism who used
permission from whichever government
controls the land or has the land
believes it has sovereignty of the land
to you know, to to take that land uh
from its inhabitants, i.e. from by
creating a sovereignty which is not the
sovereignty of its inhabitants, but the
sovereignty of those who are coming into
it. How is that different to settler
colonialism? If it looks like a duck, if
it quacks like a duck, and the duck says
it's a duck, well then it's a duck. On
to Herzl. To begin with,
the quotes that you brought, Abdullah,
were actually talking about Argentina.
And he actually If you read his diaries,
when he talks about the promised land,
he says the promised land is within us.
It's it's the ability for us to create a
state to state to escape Mizraim. The
9th of June, 19 1895. This is what he
says in his diary. Again, the diary that
you've read. In Palestine's disfavor, it
is it's In Palestine's disfavor is its
proximity to Russia and Europe, its lack
of room for expansion as well as its
climate, which we are no longer
accustomed to. He's he's obviously
speaking as a European Jew from
a pretty cold climate. In its favor is
the mighty legend. Obviously, for him,
he's not a religious person and he sees
the connection of the Jews to land as a
some mighty legend. But yeah, what he's
effectively saying is our our strong
connection to this place.
And so,
what we see from here is when Herzl's
writing to himself, and this is why he
favors Argentinia which is Argentinia
which is going to lead into the next
point. But
when he's writing to himself, he's
honest. And he he does his concern with
Palestine is it's close to the Europeans
and the Russians. He doesn't want to be
in that mix. He doesn't want to be in
the mix of the Ottomans. That's crazy
for him. He wants to be in the new world
where he's safe, where the Jews won't
have to worry about these superpowers
that will
oppress them like they have done since
the Jews were exiled um 2,000 years ago.
You mentioned a very famous quote. And
what again you failed to mention was
he's not talking about Palestine. He's
talking about Argentina. And it was the
penniless quote. And so, let me let me
read the entire passage and then explain
what it says. So,
when we occupy the So, again, this is
12th of June, 1895. When we occupy the
land, we shall bring immediate He's
talking about Argentina here. We shall
bring immediate benefits to the state
that rece- state that receives us. We
must expropriate gently the private
property on the estates assigned to us.
So, he's already saying this is land
that's been assigned to us.
Not coming in by force. We shall try to
spirit the penniless population across
the border. We shall try to spirit away
the private penniless population across
the border by procuring employment for
it in the transit countries. So, nothing
about expulsion. It's like we're going
to help them by giving them work in
other countries which will be better for
them. This is Herzl speaking, not me. Or
there's a sentiment of Herzl. While
denying it any employment in our own
country because he wants to build up a
Jewish state where Jews have autonomy,
which they don't have in Europe. Um
If we move in and so it it goes on and
on and on, but
effectively
he's not talking about Palestine. He's
talking about Argentina. He's talking
about people who don't own the land.
He's talking about people who live on
the land, who are penniless, and he's
saying we can help them get employment
elsewhere. Let's go back to what you
said about Theodor Herzl. So, Theodor
Herzl's diary quote was
written in the summer of 1895.
Um at that point, he actually hadn't
decided whether it was going to be
Palestine or Argentina. Um so, he didn't
reference any particular country. So,
when you said that he was referring to
Argentina,
that's uh that's not exactly true,
right? And you know, um he he didn't
actually mention any particular he was
hadn't yet decided at that point whether
it was going to be Argentina or
Palestine. But, you missed the point of
the entire quote, which is he might have
even if I was to concede it was
Argentina, even if I was to give you
that,
he's still outlining what he intends to
do to any place. He wants to colonize
somewhere, all right? The question is
where? Where's the target?
Um Zionism wouldn't be any less settler
colonialist just because it targets
Argentina.
Okay, so it's a moot point. So, you're
you're basically arguing that well, you
know, he yeah, he was going to settle
colonize some place, but he hadn't
decided it was Palestine at that point.
It was like, well, all right, but that
still doesn't change the point that
Zionism is settler colonialism. So, um
that needs to be really addressed.
If you enjoyed the arguments presented
in the debate and want to know more and
learn how to debate, discuss, and
advocate for Palestine yourself,
register now for the Palestine advocacy
course and raise the bar in Muslim
argument and activism. Please follow
this link. The link is also available in
the description.